40 minutes que nous avons perdu 40
minutes où nous ne débattons pas des
retraites 40 minutes de perdues pour le
débat qu'attendent les Français alors
oui posons la question qui dans cette
hémicycle fait la courte échelle à
l'extrême droite
sauf qui dans cette musique le vote le
plus avec le rassemblement national
c'est vous nous voulons débattre et nous
sommes ici pour débattre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment avez-vous pu refuser la motion
référendaire que nous avons déposé au
nom de ces 58 députés pour éviter qu'il
y ait un vote
en faisant cela madame la Présidente
vous participez vous participez au déni
de démocratie qui est la procédure qui a
été utilisée par ce gouvernement pour
éviter le vote de l'Assemblée nationale
madame la Présidente ceci a un nom cela
s'appelle une manœuvre et nous la voyons
gros lorsque cette troisième motion
référendaire a été déposée elle a été
déposée monsieur de course sur la très
bien dit elle a été déposée dans les
délais il n'y a aucune raison pour que
vous rejetiez cette troisième motion
référendaire si ce n'est de rajouter
encore un déni démocratique au coup de
force que vous êtes en train de faire au
million de Français qui manifestent dans
ce pays nous avons proposé à l'ensemble
des groupes qui ont déposé la motion les
six groupes on leur a dit écoutez nous
on est prêt à retirer la nôtre si vous
acceptez la signature des députés
rassemblement national pour qu'il y ait
véritablement une motion transpartisane
et jusqu'à présent vous avez refusé
alors maintenant halte
a la tartiflerie
[Applaudissements]
la question qui se pose aujourd'hui à
nous c'est de savoir que faut-il faire
de cette troisième motion référendum
Vous réclamez un nouveau tirage au sort
je vous indique que conformément à ce
que nous faisons pour l'émotion de rejet
nous ne referons pas un tirage au sort
parce que tel n'est pas nos règles le
tirage au sort a été effectué et là
encore mon cher collègue
là encore mon cher collègue vous
aujourd'hui vous allez vous allez
défendre aujourd'hui une émotion de
rejet préalable cette notion de rejet
préalable vous avez été vous a été
attribué partira au sort d'autres
groupes politiques ont déposé une motion
de rejet préalable postérieurement au
tirage au sort et je note que vous ne
demandez pas pour cela un nouveau tirage
au sort aussi donc moi je vous avoue que
les règles à géométrie variable
c'est ça
dont il faut se détourner
de l'Assemblée nationale
[Applaudissements]